m
dans un bar de la piscine kaffrine ce
concours de karaoké et une belle excuse
pour chanter c'est bon signe
mathieu a parcouru près de 250
kilomètres pour participer à ce concours
il a le karaoké dans la peau il s'est
même fait tatouer sur la poitrine
l'amusé et le langage des émotions je
voyage et qu'elle est montréal jamais
mis du groupe iec moi on sait jamais
souhaité l'occasion qu'on peut tomber on
sait jamais quand on peut tomber sur un
management on peut tomber sur n'importe
qui non seulement des cadres au québec
at il
maiko un retraité du milieu bancaire est
lui aussi en demi finale du concours car
aosta c'est le contact avec le public
qu'il allume des meetings
[Musique]
c'est toujours un plaisir avec ou sans
le concours qui en est à sa quatrième
année a réuni 70 personnes en audition
pour la demi-finale des spectateurs
embarque 4 ont même si jeannie est une
habituée du karaoké c'est la première
fois qu'elle participe à une compétition
chanter j'ai toujours aimé ça c'est
quelque chose qui libérateur pour moi
incapable d'être un poteau roulant comme
ceux montés sur une scène qui tu
acceptes mme sita conditions aujourd'hui
je capable de dire que je n'aime plus
que jamais ce soir là
michael jasny et mathieu accède à la
finale mais l'expérience vécue à une
plus grande valeur que le couronnement
l'important c'est que j'avais dû se
retourner deux jours à la suite on la
connaît pas les billets rappeler de
surprise ici judith jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal
[Musique]